this idea of the position vector right
that's basically like that the overlap
between thinking of complex numbers as
vectors which can go any way you like
and thinking of them as points in
relation to the origin so the position
vector is that particular one got
anything you need now because this is a
new way of thinking right um thinking of
them as the the intervals right I'm
trying to get across that everything we
now know about like quadrilaterals and
like regular plane geometry you can use
all of those insights and believe me
there's a lot and you can borrow them
into the complex world okay and we're
gonna explore some of them yeah as we
progressed now let's put them one is
into and me onto a new arguing diagram
and we're going to think of a new vector
this time okay so
okay now one of us the thing about now
is and we did the sum of these two
convicts numbers of makyo okay every
time we have a new representation we
think about you know let's just go back
to the basics and think about what the
basics mean in this particular context
so if this was the song and that's where
next place to go is the difference so
let's think about subtraction is n1
minus EPSA now where is this guy
normally is everyone - Zed - where would
you think of him normally okay now if
you remember when we first looked at
subtraction we said subtraction is
really edition with a negations you're
gonna burn up do you recall that okay so
is there one money said - is Zed 1 plus
negative Z - well I know we're negatives
into on my diagram belongs right it's
rotation around the origin by how far PI
radians right I've gone all the way
around
um I would be pi/2 but I thought thank
you one which is up two pi radians okay
so that's I said two is then negative
two or three down here I draw the
seventh on it for me because not our
main point there's negative century now
z1 right Plus this addition is just
translation right it's just translating
so therefore what I really want to do is
go up here right along this vector and
remembering that addition is stringing
along a series of vectors one after the
other right I can move negative 2 a 2
like this is what it is if it starts
from the origin this is the position
vector of negative Z - what I'm going to
do is I want to move it over here so see
this new don't line I just drew right
this is no longer a position vector
it doesn't start from the origin and you
want we call this guy the free vector u
moves around I'm gonna write that down
the same but ok where is this where is
it so this is step one I've subtracted
so I'm down here let's give this poor
today let's call this on let's called
this one seats
this is zeg one take away the zetsu if i
draw them back tonight
whoops oh yeah no anybody okay if that
line down there are you happy with that
idea do you see by the way why at least
rotationally why it has to be down there
right which complex number has a bigger
argument is it one was it to your
argument be wrong it
so the is that choose the variety right
because here is the argument moves in
one right and then here is the argument
Thomson - it's bigger okay well if you
do said one takeaway said - what happens
to the arguments you subtract yeah so
you've got a small line you would take
away a big argument so your argument is
negative right so you've got this way
okay but I want to push on this just a
little bit further right oh she is
though let's write this down Oh Celie is
the position vector
I'm saying what - ed - because it starts
from the origin
but there's another representation I can
use as a different vector for OC sorry
for Z 1 minus a 2 that's even more
valuable okay this guy over here have a
look CUA he is right
do you agree but if I choose it 1 plus
negative Z 2 that's the same as doing
negative Z 2 and then take one do you
agree with that so that's still going to
take me off in here right but if I free
up where I'm starting do you see that
it's gonna be exactly the same picked up
as this guy right to see why all my
vectors if they're equal interaction and
equal in magnitude right we form
parallelograms everywhere you see I'm
trying to borrow everything I know from
plain geometry okay so this blue line
that I've done here which is like this
it's be a it's not a B it's B to a right
do you see that it's the same as this
vector right there the same vector I
just moved one a different starting
point not starting from the origin
anymore it's starting from babe okay but
it's still just as much as C right or
see you later tonight
ba is just as much that vector it has
the same magnitude and it has the same
direction okay so I'm gonna say VA is
I'm not gonna say V because it's it's
not unique it's a free vector all that
same complex number zero my decision
now the reason why I like this is
because think about it back in terms of
this parallelogram we had in our example
in here okay where is this parallelogram
all of that diagram it sits out going
further into first quadrant right in
fact because all of these vectors are
all the same vector right same magnitude
same direction I can make another
parallelogram up here right
so what said what - said - this was a
long diagonal and at least on my diagram
so all - said - is the short diagonal
right it's not always going to be the
short diagonal because depending on the
ways n1 is that to relate to each other
one will be long and one will be short
or with the other way around
but it's the other one okay so I'm gonna
say Zed one take position is the length
of the other diagonal the person silver
plus it